Matt Hancock says that he's the victim
of a massive betrayal and breach of
trust it's in his latest statement after
the disclosure of WhatsApp messages
revealing the inside working of
government during the worst of the
pandemic they also reveal an apparent
dispute with the then education
secretary Gavin Williamson about closing
schools in his statement released in the
last hour Matt Hancock says there's
absolutely no public interest case for
this huge breach all the materials for
the book have already been made
available to the inquiry which is the
right and only place for everything to
be considered properly and the right
lessons to be learned I will not be
commenting further on any other stories
or false allegations that Isabel Isabel
oakshot will make I will respond to the
substance in the appropriate place at
the inquiry so that we can properly
learn all the lessons based on a full
and objective understanding of what
happened in the pandemic and why
has also responded in a series of tweets
he said further to reports in the
Telegraph and other outlets I wish to
clarify that these messages were about
some unions and not teachers as
demonstrated in the exchange I was
responding regarding unions he went on
to say I have the utmost respect for
teachers who work tirelessly to support
students
that was Gavin Williamson's response but
the head of a teaching Union told me the
comments were contemptible
there was a recognition but at a time of
huge National anxiety that if we were to
win the hearts and minds of parents that
it was now safe to send their children
back in the only way you would be able
to do that is by having the teaching
profession as the front line workers
when there was no vaccination program
and all of that stuff stepping up and
doing it and that's what they did and
that's why there's a particular sense
from me of how contemptible those
comments are denigrating stereotyping
teachers when they were the very people
who the nation needed to focus on young
people in the way that the government
hadn't
interesting to see there was a battle of
words between the edu then education
secretary and the then Health secretary
as to whether or not it was the right
thing to do to open schools where are
you on that
oh I you know the the territory that I
exist in is about education and what I
know is that the people who I represent
school and college leaders were being
told yes we're going to open schools and
colleges and they need to be face
coverings now you'll remember as well as
I do that became a hugely contentious
issue where I was being asked by
interviews what do you think about face
coverings and I was saying I haven't I
don't know anything about face coverings
we have to be able to trust the
scientists and what today is showing us
is that this kind of political
government by WhatsApp and an arms race
between what England says and Scotland
says is a million miles away from the
principled ethical leadership that
school and college leaders were trying
to do
earlier in the program I spoke to
conservative MP Tobias Elwood about the
WhatsApp messages this is what he said
would you release all your WhatsApp
messages no I wouldn't I think that's I
mean I think that was done for personal
gain and I'm sorry about that you know a
bigger picture look what has happened
this last week with our conservative
party for the first time we've
Illustrated some statecraft and I've not
seen for quite some time that's what the
electorate wants to see uh Richie sunac
managed to land that deal which showed
what happens when you have leadership
determination Vision Focus bridge
building rather than the bombastic
partisan aggression that we've had in
the past we're starting to regroup you
saw that in the chamber yesterday in
prime minister's questions that's what
we should be illustrating a new culture
of wanting to do what's best for the
nation so all these stories about what's
happened in the past now you know I
think are a distractions to where we
want to go
Mara's here so and the mood music is
building about whether you release
WhatsApp messages yes Matt Hancock has
put out a statement today and the first
on the record comment he's made since
the release of these messages yesterday
and he's been already done it actually
pretty angry about it yeah um Isabella
shot the journalist says it was in the
public interest for her to release them
um the Rouse in in the telegraph that
are revealed by these messages today we
have uh between Mr Hancock and Gavin
Williamson about whether schools should
reopen in January 2021 Mr Hancock
arguing that they shouldn't he mounted a
rear God action to stop it happening and
in fact um Gavin Williamson um who had
battled to keep them open was said in
these messages to have had to eat Humble
Pie we all parents I'm sure will
remember the chaotic scenes when the
Prime Minister Boris Johnson went on
television to say schools would open in
January of complete reverse fair at 24
hours later when they suddenly closed
again and yesterday Dave of course we
saw the devastating evidence about about
Care Homes and suggestions that advice
wasn't followed Matt Hancock's team very
strongly about that saying that they
didn't have the testing capacity in fact
what may be more interesting is the fact
that the the way decision making was
made in government with these streams of
WhatsApp messages minis is criticizing
each other and labor Stephen Morgan uh
picked up on that he's the shadow
schools minister
hi uh let's start with whether you would
release all your WhatsApp messages
well they'd be pretty boring to be
honest okay but would you do it
um would you no
well I think to end encryption you know
people are talking to you privately I'm
sure there's some data protection rules
that have been broken now I mean call me
old-fashioned but I think you should
govern the country via meetings with
civil servants in the room with minutes
of meetings
um I think this is about him promoting
his book is it not a breach of trust
absolutely but I mean it's not the first
time that the government have preached
the trust of the British people is it
um so I think lessons have got to be
learned and the key is right to raise
with the Prime Minister that we need to
bring forward the code inquiry to
lessons could be learned for the future
I think Matt Hancock would dispute that
it was that he's breached trust he says
that he put his trust in the journalist
Isabel Workshop who was writing his book
the pandemic Diaries last year and that
she betrayed his trust by using them for
these stories which I'm sure will run
and run for many days if not weeks I'm
sure they will for now tomorrow thanks
very much indeed